today on the matt walsh show as law
enforcement officials say there's no
evidence of a racially motivated hate
crime in the atlanta mass shooting last
week the left becomes increasingly
desperate to connect the event to racism
but as always in the rush to make
everything about race
they miss what really motivated this
shooting and so there's a really
important conversation
we don't end up having but we will have
today also five headlines including the
canceled dominoes continue to fall as
another teen vogue employee
has her own racist tweets from the past
resurfaced and a viral tick tock video
proves again
that all cyclists are psychopaths and
finally in our daily cancellation i have
to address the man
who stormed off an elevator yesterday
when i committed the sin of getting on
the elevator without a mask
you know that's going into the daily
cancellation all of that and much more
today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
so we're going to connect all this back
to the race issue eventually but bear
with me here you know there's been
for some time a so-called rape epidemic
on college campuses this is what has led
to the formation of
kangaroo courts rape tribunals at these
universities where men are often
kicked out of school based on
unsubstantiated claims without evidence
to back them up
in many cases as we've seen the rape
claims end up being erroneous but of
course the
men's lives are destroyed anyway what
makes false rape claims
such a problem today is that the
definition of what qualifies as rape has
been expanded
into incoherence and this is because
consent which used to be a rather simple
and straightforward concept
has been turned into an impossible
calculus equation
consent is no longer a simple matter of
agreeing to do something
you know traditionally that's what
consent is if you agree to do it you
consent it
period someone can agree now
they can willingly engage in a
particular act and yet somewhat somehow
still not have consented to it a woman
might
wake up the morning after a sexual
escapade with a guy
on campus and though she was a willing
and eager participant at the time
nonetheless concluded that she didn't
really consent and was therefore raped
well there goes that guy's life and
reputation
the fundamental problem is that our
culture has gotten rid
of all of the rules all of the moral
guidelines governing the sexual act
leaving only consent as sort of the last
of the mohicans the straggler the final
moral boundary hanging on for dear life
consent is the only commandment
we have left in the realm of sex and so
when a sexual act
violates some other moral guideline one
that we don't recognize anymore
we don't have the language with which to
describe it or condemn it and so
with consent being our only available
term we apply it there as well
a woman wakes up after a consensual
sexual encounter with a stranger she met
at a party or something
and and and maybe she feels used and she
feels violated and she was
used and violated but not because it was
non-consensual
those feelings arise from the fact that
the sexual act
was not loving it was not committed it
was not respecting of her own or her
partner's dignity
but again she doesn't have the moral
language available
so she says well this doesn't feel good
you know it feels bad so it must have
been raped all non-rape sex is good
this was bad so what else could this be
but rape
this is the danger of embracing all
sins but one collapsing our morality
down to this one specific evil evil
deciding that all of our problems can be
boiled down to just this one thing
with sex we end up thinking that our
only problem
is simply that so much of it is
non-consensual
when we have many more problems in the
in the area of sexual morality than that
and so much insanity and wickedness
springs from that gross
oversimplification now a similar thing
is happening with racism
last week after a after a man a white
man as we're constantly reminded
murdered eight people at massage parlors
in atlanta
the immediate and sustained assumption
from the media and and much of the
culture has been that it was an act of
anti-anti
racism no other possibility is
entertained
it must have been racial hatred must
have been
this in spite of the fact that the
killer also murdered two white people
and despite the fact that the killer who
is in police custody now
told them why he did it and said it
wasn't it was not any sort of racial
statement
he identified himself as a sex addict
who was trying to eliminate and punish
his temptations
so it was it was sexual rage sexual
jealousy sexual madness that led him to
this
according to the man who actually
committed the act who you would think is
perhaps not an authority on anything
else in life but at least an authority
on why he does the things that he does
but this explanation is simply not being
accepted
it can't be that we're told it must be
racism
representative judy chu of california
was on abc news this weekend
declaring that she's sure it was
anti-asian racism she's sure of it
not because she has any intel that we
don't have but just because she can't
imagine any other reason her own
incredulity
has led her to this verdict as she
explained let's listen
investigators say they haven't found
concrete evidence
that the gunman in atlanta targeted
these businesses and
victims because of their ethnicity
ethnicities
but do you believe that this was a hate
crime against asian americans
and should be prosecuted as such
first my heart breaks for the eight
victims and as i read more about them i
see that they were hard-working
many were mothers one was as old as 74
years old
and yes i do strongly believe that this
is a hate crime
this is a 21 year old white male who
chose as his first
victim and business that was called
young's asian massage then he drove for
27
miles to another spot where he hit
two more asian spas if
his only problem was sex addiction
then he could have had his choice in
those 27 miles of
any place that he could have gone to but
no he specifically went to those asian
spas
where it was clear in all three places
there would be many asian women and
indeed
those were the majority of those that he
shot
and killed now i know the legal bar
is high because they have to find
somebody who heard him
say that there was a
an anti-asian slur expressed at the time
but i would say look these were places
where
people spoke another language they may
not have heard him they may be dead
but in my mind and in the minds of many
this
is an anti-asian hate crime
oh in her mind well okay then that's all
you need but
in judy choo's mind it's an anti-asian
hate crime
that's it doesn't the evidence evidence
be damned
in her mind that's what it is in her
mind and heart
what kind of thing is that to even say
in my mind and heart the motive of this
crime is
what the hell are you talking about it
doesn't matter what's in your mind judy
chu
there doesn't appear to be much there
actually it doesn't matter what's in
your mind it matters
what's in the mind of the person who
committed the act
his motivation matters when deciding on
a hate crime
but you see judy chu is a better
authority on the shooter's motivation
than the shooter is himself she has we
must assume
dialed up miss cleo calling her out of
retirement been given this information
through psychic insight
and many in the media and on the on the
left apparently have access to the same
supernatural powers
because they've decided it was
anti-asian racism
now why do this i mean why twist into
pretzels to connect this to racism
usually when a person commits murder to
make some sort of point
whether political or racial or whatever
they're not going to be shy about
announcing that point
far from it i mean normally they have
they have manifestos and everything they
want you to know
the point was after all the whole point
of the terrible deed itself
whatever whatever point they were trying
to make they're not going to be shy
about telling you
in this case if the killer wanted to
send some sort of twisted message about
asians
you'd think he'd tell us what the
message is
instead he gives some other reason so
why not take him at his word it's not as
though accepting the sex addict line
would be letting him off the hook
it's nobody is saying well he's a sex
addict let him out of jail
it's not as though it makes him
sympathetic it's not an excuse
whether motivated by racism or sexual
rage
he's just as evil either way
why refuse to believe the true motive as
he tells it
part of the reason is the standard deal
you know that the media is always eager
to pin whatever it can on white
supremacy or
quote unquote whiteness so that's part
of it and we've talked about that plenty
but
another part of the reason an important
part
is the limitation of our modern moral
imagination
it's been decided that just as the only
sin in the realm of sex
is to violate consent the only sin in
the realm of
well everything else is racism
racism is the root of all evil racism is
all evil whatever is evil must be racism
if it's evil it's racism if it isn't
racism it isn't evil
this is where our great moral condensing
has brought us
we're condensing everything down to this
everything is about racism
and that's a real shame because many
truths are left on the cutting room
floor many evils go undiagnosed and
undenounced and therefore are allowed to
flourish
this man says he had a porn compulsion a
pornography compulsion that led to a sex
addiction
that's what he says according to law
enforcement officials
so rather than talking about how racism
contributed to a shooting that
it apparently didn't contribute to it
all we could be talking about how
pornography contributed to it
porn by its nature dehumanizes and
degrades
both the viewer and the viewed are
lessened by the experience
the person on the screen is made into a
mere thing to be consumed
a commodity and the viewer is made into
a voyage
a passive watcher hiding in the cyber
bushes
peeking through the window it is
profoundly demeaning
everyone involved has their view of
themselves and the world and their
fellow human beings
warped they walk away changed and not
for the better
is that part of the story here did this
man grow more and more
uh accustomed to to seeing women as
objects to be used and discarded
did he grow to hate himself and hate the
world and hate his own sexual impulses
it seems so and these are important
questions ones that we need to ask
and try to answer because this guy is
not the only one who has conditioned
himself to see his fellow human beings
as nothing but tools or props to be used
up and thrown away
so there's a real urgency to these
questions
but we ignore them completely we insist
on the only explanation we recognize
anymore
racism we're like homeowners who've
decided that the only thing worth
worrying about in the
in the home is is fixing and maintaining
the plumbing
and so we sit in our houses as they burn
from an electrical fire
confident that all is well because at
least the toilet's still flush
we're focused on one problem to the
exclusion of all others
often often inventing examples of the
problem where it doesn't exist
while real problems tear our country and
its people into pieces
and that's what's happening here again
and it is a great evil
in and of itself let's get now to our
five headlines
before we get to five headlines today
you know with so many companies these
days that are getting increasingly woke
and uh seems purposefully alienating
their
non-woke customer base it's nice to have
companies out there
a few anyway that still support us and
support our values in the court
in the culture companies that have
morals and that would be first and
foremost
charity mobile one company that
certainly fits the description is
charity mobile the pro-life phone
company
and with the pro-life phone company that
means that five percent of your monthly
plan price goes to the pro-life pro
family charity of your choice
um and now through april 16
new activations get a free cell phone
after instant credit plus free
activations free shipping and a free
pro-life keychain you get all of that
through april 16th so you're getting
you're you're you're helping to support
the right to life you're helping to
support a culture of life in america but
you're also getting a great service with
a lot of perks no contract no
termination fees and no risk
uh no risk with a 30 day guarantee so
you might as well try it out plus you
get live customer service
based right here in the usa uh you get
free usage alerts a free app to monitor
your usage which is uh which is really
convenient pay your bills as well
all of that but again the main thing
you're helping to build a culture of
life in america while supporting a
pro-life phone company so call them at
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com so this new justice
league movie came out a couple days ago
lots of people talking about it uh came
out i think it was hbo max
and zach was that was a zack snyder's
justice league
and that it's you got batman and
superman and uh and aquaman and wonder
woman
all teaming up to to save the world
again
and it's never exactly clear to me
like i know they i know they jump
through all the hoops to explain why
this is necessary but
it's never clear to me why superman
would ever need
help from some dude he's superman
he can literally do anything i think in
the comics
one because back when i was a kid i
would read the comics there was a comic
where he actually moved the entire
planet out of the way of an asteroid or
something i believe that did happen so
that's what he can do and he needs help
from some guy
with some toys in his belt anyway
a lot of people are talking about this
and um i haven't seen it personally
and the thing is you know i was gonna
watch justice league but then i
remembered
that i'm not a child and so that's why i
don't watch
superhero films so i just i just had to
remember oh yeah i'm not a 12 year old
boy so that's why i'm not
i'm not interested in that personally
and i i know this what is this one rated
r they say the the
the the f word a few times trying to
make it gritty and realistic and adult
it's not it's for kids
superheroes are for children once you
get over like the age of 14
you should have grown out of them okay
[Music]
all of them don't don't tell me oh
christopher nolan's batman was no not
really
still a silly movie about a guy running
around in a rubber suit i mean that's at
the end of the day that's what it's
about
uh and yeah this is another opinion of
mine along with hating dogs that i'm
sure
there will be universal agreement with
um okay number one for the new york post
it says it's a senior teen vogue staffer
who opposed alexi mccammon's
hiring as editor-in-chief over troubling
tweets as a teen
had herself repeatedly dropped the
n-word in online posts according to a
report
christine davitt a senior social media
manager
at the connie nest mag had earlier this
month made public a letter by staff
complaining about mccammon's hiring
in light of her past racist and
homophobic tweets so this was
we talked about this last week alexa
mccammond was hired to be she's a
very left-wing black woman who was hired
to be the editor-in-chief
hired from axios to be editor chief of
teen vogue
and there was this cancel campaign that
started within
the teen vogue ranks because of some
tweets that alexie mccammon had sent out
10 years ago when she was 17
which were really pretty innocuous at
the end of the day especially because it
was a 17 year old
sending them but she got cancelled for
that
and now we know that one of the the
people at teen vogue this um
uh christine davitt who was involved in
canceling
uh alexi mccammond had herself when she
was a teenager
also sent out uh racist tweets
so davitt wrote uh on
her twitter after mccammon was
fired she wrote so proud of my teen
vogue colleagues the work continues
then just hours after mccamid announced
the resignation saying that her tweets
as a 17 year old college student have
overshadowed her work since then
davitt wrote on twitter uh quote
exhales the deepest sigh of ever sighed
so she was relieved
finally we got rid of this racist yet
david who calls herself a queer fat
philippines femme in brooklyn
um that's how i describe myself too
actually it's
incidentally uh no she says she's a
queer fat
philip pinks okay so we've already i
guess i should have figured we were
gonna do this we're doing la tinx
said a latino or latina now we're doing
a set of filipino we're saying philip
pinks
but turns out she had she still had up
on her twitter old posts of her own in
which she repeatedly dropped the n-word
she at least twice the post reports
referred to a friend who appears to be
white
as a quote n-word with the with the a at
the end not the er but still
in 2009 in the next year also she used
the n-word in a joke tweet
um and those have since been
resurfaced i don't know now she's gonna
have to lose her job too
you know the the the dominoes fall
you get held to your own standard
now in reality again
it would be it's completely crazy
objectively speaking it is completely
crazy that we would be holding anyone
accountable
for tweets they sent out in 2009 you
know when they were teenagers
it's a completely crazy thing to do
but you how can we not hold you to your
own standard you were
just insisting that someone else get
fired for the same damn thing
so of course we have to apply it to you
we have no choice
i don't i don't like it really
personally
what choice do we have though this is
your standard this is what you this is
the world
you wanted to live in and so now we're
going to allow you to live in it
it's what you wanted you said
now uh and it keeps going meanwhile a
woman named ellery smith
apparently a comedy writer um tweeted
after the shooting in atlanta she
tweeted this
quote remember when someone had their
snl offer revoked after using an
anti-asian slur
and so many people thought it was an
overreaction hateful language begets
violence hateful jokes beget violence
they minimize and they dehumanize and
they allow for the normalization of
terror so
um and this uh yeah she's apparently
some sort of comedian
and this is in reference to shane gillis
who was fired from snl a couple years
ago for some jokes that he had told in
the past about asians
and now ellery smith is bringing that
back up and saying
and actually partially blaming shane
gillis as if he hadn't been canceled
enough he lost his job
but partially blaming him for the
shooting in in atlanta
yes because i'm sure that the shooter
who even though he
he never indicated he had any anti-asian
sentiments at all
uh elder smith has decided not only did
he have anti-asian sentiments
but he was motivated partially by shane
gillis's jokes about asians
well because she said that some
enterprising person on twitter went
through ellery ellery smith's old tweets
and found
found at least one from 2013 where she
jokes about how thai
food has has uh has cats in it you know
the old joke about
asian food having cats and dogs and she
made a joke like that in 2013.
that came up and this is how she
responded to the guy who who
brought that old tweet up she said i
posted a tasteless racist tweet when i
was 17.
it was disgusting and normalized the
exact kind of violence that i meant
luckily i had been willing and slash
able to grow in the past eight years so
i look a lot more like the girl in the
left on the left referring to her most
recent tweet than i do on the right
well there it is again now
and and once more normal circumstances
if we're speaking objectively who cares
about the tweet she sent
in 2013 when i guess she was a teenager
even if she wasn't a teenager
a joke about how asians have cats and
dogs so what
by the way that's a stereotype that
isn't it didn't
it wasn't we don't pull it out of thin
air
that is an actual thing that has
happened and does happen in some asian
countries
so you make a joke about it who cares
even if she made the joke yesterday who
cares
that doesn't normalize violence in no if
you make a joke about asian cuisine
in no way shape or form are you
encouraging or even
implying or insinuating that anyone
should commit any violence at all
against anybody
obviously
but she herself was trying to pin a
harmless joke
on someone else made it supposedly an
anti-asian joke and she
that's that's her standard even though
it's crazy
we have no choice but to apply it to her
but of course she gets to say oh i've
grown since then i'm a different i'm
changed
so that's the thing you notice about the
cancel culture mob they get to grow
right they get to change and grow and
become different people
no one else is allowed to they're
allowed to
no then see we can't we can't go along
with that what we have now
is this is a it's become a war of
attrition
this is mutually assured destruction
if this is the game you want to play
it's going to be turned back on you
right like this a nuclear cold war um
that's what this is you don't want to
get
you don't want to lose your job over
dumb stuff that you said 10 years ago
then don't try to do it to other people
i think that's pretty reasonable in the
end all right uh
number two uh you know of course we have
the the trip heard round the world
joe biden you've already seen it we
don't need to play the video you saw the
video of joe biden tripping
not just once but three times going up
the steps on friday uh
on his way to boarding i believe it was
air force one
and he it was it was it's not
merely i mean look i'm a clumsy guy i'm
as clumsy as they come i've
i have tripped many a time going up and
down steps i will admit but tripping
three times on your way up the steps
like you just can't get your feet under
you that's not
that that's more than being clumsy that
is you being a
frail old man who is in the process of
physically and mentally
uh disintegrating and the one thing i'll
say about this
i i think there's been more than enough
analysis of joe biden tripping on the
steps
especially when it yeah it's disturbing
to see
and and all of that but it of course
this is what we're gonna see it's
what we expect when you when you elect a
78 year old man to be president
this is what you're gonna get we are
mortal human beings
it's there's it's not a fun thing nobody
likes it
part of being mortal is that as you get
older your mind starts to go your body
starts could happen to all of us
unless you die before it happens it will
happen to you
that's the unfortunate that's the ugly
reality right
the one thing i will say is um you hear
even
plenty of conservatives that uh will
will say
that they feel sorry for joe biden that
we should make jokes about it
it's it's a sad thing to see him falling
apart like this
well maybe this is because i'm not a
very compassionate guy in general but
let me say i don't feel sorry for him i
really don't
um because this is a guy who's been
chasing power
his whole life it's not as though he he
just went insane and has acted
no he's been chasing power his whole
life
he has been trying to be president for
decades
and so he put himself in this position
yeah there are a lot of people close to
him like his wife who should have
stepped in
and didn't and they deserve a lot of the
blame for this
the great quote dr jill biden who we're
supposed to see just like joe biden
we're supposed to see her
as this decent person no if you're a
decent and good wife
you would not have allowed your husband
to do this
you would have absolutely put your foot
down and say i'm not gonna go along with
this
if it came down to it you you go on
camera if it's the only way to stop him
you go on camera and you say listen
joe biden he is not well i am not
in i'm not on board with his
presidential run
you do anything you can to stop this if
you really love your husband
so i put a lot of blame there but also
joe biden himself
chasing power all he cares about
a lot of these people hillary clinton
was the same thing
she was falling apart physically whose
fault is that
she couldn't let go of it all she wanted
was power joe biden that's all he wanted
and now he's falling apart in front of
the entire world and that
that is on him that's the decision that
he made
um this is the consequence of chasing
power and
and for that being the only thing you
care about in the world
number three trump advisor jason miller
uh was on fox over the weekend
and he announced that trump is working
on
building his own social media platform
so big big news there
let's listen to that donald trump
obviously has been booted off twitter
and facebook and instagram which were a
great megaphone for him does he plan
to try to get back on social media
perhaps with some new outfit
you know harry this is really
interesting the fact that the
president's been off of social media for
a while because
his press releases his statements have
actually been getting almost more play
than he ever did on twitter before
i'm not sure if that's because the
length of them were a bit longer even
had
one reporter say that she thought it was
much more elegant
the way that the president was able to
communicate his thoughts and very much
looked more presidential in that longer
form
but i do think that we're going to see
president trump returning
to social media and probably about two
or three months here with his
own platform and this is something i
think will be the
the hottest ticket in social media it's
going to completely redefine the game
and everybody is going to be waiting and
watching to see what exactly president
trump does but it will be his own
platform
well we'll see that's an interesting
idea uh i
i will admit that i'm of course you come
to me to be
the naysayer so doing a little naysaying
here i'm
very skeptical of this idea we'll see if
it actually happens
but in order to have a successful
run at starting your own social media
platform if you want it to be
you know big if you want it to be a a
major factor as we just heard from jason
miller
a couple of things number one trump is
going to have to
uh delegate what does donald trump
really know about starting a
social media company he's successful in
using social media it doesn't mean that
you know anything
behind the scenes to to to actually
operate this on your own which
and that's fine so you got to delegate
you got to find people who know this
stuff
and who you could trust and
and uh and let them do it
but delegating responsibility finding
good candidates for a job
delegating responsibility that is not
proven to be one of donald trump's
strong suits that's my first issue
second issue is that we know with trump
part of his branding is like he likes to
put his name on everything he does
if it's a hotel he's starting it's a
trump hotel if it stakes that he's
has his own line of stakes they're trump
stakes whatever it is he puts trump on
it
and yeah you could start he could start
whatever trump
social media side and call it trump or
call it mega or something
and uh you you're probably guaranteed to
get like
10 or 20 million users and you could
have a successful little operation that
way
but twitter has 160 170 million users
facebook has billions of users
so if you want to be major and you want
to make a play
to get into that category and you want
to make a serious dent
in twitter and facebook and take a lot
of it take a
a huge chunk of their users then it
can't be the trump social media platform
it has to be
just a regular social media platform
that trump is
helping to run behind the scenes
but if it's a trump branded thing then
you're only going to get
trump die hards on it and there are a
lot of them but not enough to
be the next twitter or anything close to
that
so we'll see um number four on saturday
elon musk tweeted uh
saying i'm accumulating resources to
help make life multi-planetary and
extend the light of consciousness to the
stars
now not many people can say something
like that and it it's actually true but
that is really what he's doing and
taking and taking actual steps
to uh to see that through bernie sanders
though responded saying
space travel is an exciting idea but
right now we need to focus on earth and
create a progressive tax system
so that children don't go hungry people
are not homeless and all americans have
health care
the level of inequality in america is
obscene and a threat to our democracy
well we know bernie sanders is a
one-note guy so everything for him is
going to come back down to that
but you hear this a lot not just from
guys like bernie sanders and not just
from the left
any time the topic of space exploration
comes up whether elon musk or
or in general you hear from people
saying well we've got a lot of problems
on earth
let's solve those first and then we can
so what you're actually saying
is let's never do any space exploration
because there are always going to be
major problems on earth
always back in the age of exploration
when european countries were putting
people on ships and they were going
across the ocean blue and discovering
new lands and all that
um they had a lot of problems there too
far from from
far from a perfect utopian world
and yet they still push forward
and there are a lot of practical reasons
for exploration just like there are
practical reasons to try to go
into the stars uh you know mining for
resources that would be one of them
but i think it's so much more than that
it's this is what makes us human beings
this is this is a sign of a thriving
successful proper
prosperous civilization is when you're
you're pushing forward and
discovering and expanding
for its own sake
when you pull back from that and you
turn entirely inward
and you say we don't care we know as
much about the about the universe as we
want to know
we're done with that we're going to
focus only on ourselves now
and the so-called practical problems
once you do that you're in um
you're in at least a state of social
stagnation if not
collapse so uh i'm i'm not
i don't like these kinds of excuses yeah
let's but let's simply solve
world hunger hunger first let's do that
knock that out
check that box and then we can go and uh
and go to mars sure
okay number five finally a a tick tocker
who goes by the handle
angry biker 69 which probably tells you
what you need to know about this guy
proudly posted a video of himself riding
through the city
and yelling at people who dare to walk
through or even near the bike lane
and he thinks that he's the good guy
here when you watch and listen to this
video
he he posted this he thinks he's the
good guy let's uh let's watch this
way to stand great place to stay really
smart
pay attention
in case you don't know sidewalks around
your right
hey genius you're on the bike lane how
about getting
cussing out women and children i mean
this guy okay
this i i we we did a daily cancellation
about about cyclists before and this is
my this is my exhibit
i wish this video had existed back when
we did that a few weeks ago because this
is exhibit
a right here the entitled attitude
and he posted this this to uh online and
you know it goes viral
there are a lot of people defending him
so yeah he has every right to do that
what
since when is it ever acceptable
to go blowing past pedestrians flipping
them off cussing at them oh
it's like old ladies trying to cross the
street he won't even slow down for them
this is what you get from cyclists
now here's here's one thing you have to
keep in mind i actually looked this up
this is what this is what i've been
reduced to
but i looked up the surveys and
unsurprisingly the majority of people
that you see out cycling on any given
day
they're doing it for recreation it's not
even like they're
commuting now there is some of that but
your average cyclist
is out for recreation that's why he's
out why should we have to accommodate
that
at all that's my question why do we have
to
why does society have to accommodate
your hobby
there are people walking they're trying
to get from point a to point b there are
cars
that are really commuting trying to go
to work we have to make room for you
because you want to have fun on your
little bicycle
why we we we put lanes we put actual
lanes
for for your recreation why
does this have to be our problem go and
you say well where else am i gonna cycle
i don't care i don't care where else you
go on your bicycle
nowhere it's not a problem why do we
have to accommodate it that's my
question
we don't do this for any other form of
recreation we don't go out of our way
in this way to accommodate any other
recreation
it's only cyclists who are special for
whatever reason
and so do do they obey the traffic
signals they
they want they're going to enforce bike
lanes
okay you you dare cross a bike lane
stand in a bike lane
they're going to let you know it can i
do that
to cyclists who are on the on the
regular road not on the bike lane
can i honk at them can i run them off
the road
scream at them can i do that
so they don't respect the traffic you
know cyclists was like when's the last
time you saw one stopping at a red light
or actually signaling the way they're
supposed to with their hands you rarely
see that
so they're not going to obey the traffic
signals uh they're not going to obey the
rules of the road
but if you dare disobey the damn bike
lane
then it's a problem i i i was watching
that and i know that
it wasn't going to happen because he
wouldn't have posted it if it did i so
wanted someone
to throw a stick in his bicycle spokes
or just push them off that damn thing i
really wanted to see that
i i i can't tell you this is not even a
bit or a joke i cannot stand these
people
and they're stupid bike lane i don't
care about your damn bike lane
i don't respect it i don't care about it
it shouldn't exist
go go on a trail in the in the woods go
to the gym
i'm not going to accommodate you and
your hobby period
all right um got that off my chest let's
go to
reading the youtube comments marcus
aurelius
says people don't give offense they take
it if someone is angry and says that
anyone who is not angry with her is part
of the problem
that's her problem not mine yeah that's
that's one thing you get
um not only people taking offense
so often but the this idea that we we
have an obligation
like someone who takes offense it's not
only that they're taking offense
but they think you have an obligation to
be offended along with them
so we got that from the female
basketball players we played played the
video on friday
the ncaa women's tournament and and
they were offended that they didn't have
all the same accommodations as the men
which and the reason the men have all
the accommodations is because they're a
billion dollar
enterprise and everyone cares about
men's basketball and women's basketball
doesn't even make money because nobody
cares
but we were told if you don't if you're
not upset about this you're part of the
problem
it's your obligation to be offended
on behalf of female basketball players
because they don't have enough
exercise equipment yeah that um
that is an interesting thing as well
let's see mutt says teaching kids to
twerk while grown men presumably fathers
laugh
how have we fallen so far so fast these
men should be publicly shamed and
arrested for child abuse
uh in reference to the the video of a
drag queen dragon story hour teaching
kids
little kids how to twerk we played that
video and i could
not agree more that a sane stable
civilization
that video would end with law
enforcement officers
with their guns drawn running into there
and arresting
everybody who is not a child everybody
sending them all to prison um
not a dog interesting username good very
not very specific says when i was a kid
i used to want
to be a power i used to want a power
rangers tattoo really bad
um cringe i know but i was a kid
obviously mom just laughed at me as an
adult now i'm very glad that i didn't
have the chance to make permanent body
altering
decisions as a child this is this is one
of
the many arguments that you really can't
get around if you support
transitioning kids giving them hormones
well
you i would assume even you if you
support that
you would not be in favor of an
eight-year-old going to get a tattoo
most likely now maybe you'll get to that
point where you would even defend that
but right now you wouldn't you wouldn't
defend that
why is that and getting a tattoo by the
way
a much less significant bodily change
than taking hormone pills to you know um
stave off puberty or or try to try to
make it so that your body resembles
vaguely a different sex um
and finally becca says hi maddie i'm
probably going to be banned from the
show for calling you maddie
i just wanted to say i love your show
and your dry sense of humor also i just
bought my membership for the daily
wire i had to dip into my wedding fund
but i feel i deserve to give myself a
nice wedding gift plus i don't want to
miss candace owens well becca
uh your prophecies were correct you are
banned from the show
but i want to stipulate it's not so much
for calling me maddie well it is that
but also it's because you said you got a
daily wire membership for candace
well what about me so you you claim
you're a fan of the show but you didn't
weigh i mean i'm glad you got the
membership but
what am i chop liver so that's offensive
to me
and that is something i demand that
everyone else be offended by also
but so you're banned twice but thanks
for watching the show anyway
you're done now but thanks you know
spring is uh is here
and that means it's getting warmer out
you want to spend more time outside you
want to really be doing anything
but standing in an auto parts store
or walking aimlessly around looking for
the things that you the
the part that you want you're probably
not going to find it when you do find if
you do find it at all it's gonna be more
expensive than it should be
uh so why waste all that time when it's
so nice out go to rockauto.com you have
access to rockauto.com
you know in your pocket you have you
have your laptop at your desk you can go
to rockauto.com anytime in just a couple
seconds rockauto.com always offers
the lowest prices possible and that
means that they're not going to change
the prices they're not going to give you
a different price if you're a
professional or do-it-yourselfer it's
the same price for everyone
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years
you can go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
the rockauto.com catalog is unique and
remarkably easy to navigate
you quickly see all the parts that are
available for your vehicle
and you can choose the brand
specifications and prices that you
prefer they make it really really easy
even for a [ __ ] like myself
so if you're even a little bit smarter
than me it's gonna be all the all the
all the easier uh amazing selection
reliably low prices
all the parts your car will ever need at
rockauto.com so go to rockauto.com right
now see all the parts available for your
car truck and remember as always to
write walsh in there how did you hear
about us box
so they know that we sent you and you
know last week was a huge week for the
daily wire on friday candice owens
premiered her first episode of her new
talk show candice
and so many so many users tuned in to
watch that it broke our live stream for
a few minutes that's how
uh that's how popular it was and how
many people wanted to see this
if you haven't seen it yet you're
definitely going to want to check it out
you can catch key segments on her new
podcast
candace which is available on apple
podcast spotify or anywhere else
you listen but this is important only
daily wire members can get the full show
so go to dailywire.com
subscribe and get 25 off a new
membership with code candice
that's dailywire.com subscribe and 20 25
off with code candace now let's get to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
so today for our daily cancellation um
i'm going to cancel the dude on the
elevator you know who you are
this past weekend i was doing some
firearms self-defense training at front
sight in nevada it was a really
exceptional experience all around a lot
more to say about that in the coming
days but by the way if you want to have
your own exceptional experience go to
constitutioncoach.com
and you can sign up for your own course
but the the one sadly non-exceptional
event
in more than one sense of the word
happened in the elevator of the hotel on
sunday right before we left
i boarded the elevator on the third
floor
now if you could do the math that means
we had easily
fewer than 10 floors to go before
getting to the first floor i think
the point is that it was it was gonna be
a very short trip
not the kind of trip that you pack an
overnight bag for or even a bagged lunch
a few seconds and it's over if all goes
according to plan
now my case i also did not pack a mask
for the elevator trip i mean i packed
one in my bag because they wouldn't let
me on a plane without it but it was
my bag and everything was in the rental
car at this point which meant that i had
to get on the elevator
without my mask god forbid unfortunately
a man and his wife were already on the
elevator when i stepped on
and this would normally not be a problem
except that i unbeknownst to myself had
just stepped into a close quarters
environment
with an especially paranoid member of
the mask cult
so he took one look at me maskless my
entire mouth and nose exposed
naked my my face naked not the rest of
my body
presenting my hideous face shamelessly
to the world and a look of panic set in
in this guy's
eyes you could see it and he said his
voice was quaking he said
excuse me your mask can you put your
mask on
point he was pointing frantically to his
own face when he said that he's like
pointing to his mask in case i wasn't
familiar with the concept of a mask
like your mask here and i said uh oh
i think it's in the car it's fine don't
worry and then he he became especially
flustered
fuming audibly before pounding on the
button to open the door cause the door
just closed and he was fuming they
pounded on it and the door opened again
and for a brief moment i thought he was
going to demand that i
that i exit the elevator and then and
then we would have ourselves a real
showdown
because just out of principle there was
no way in hell i was ready for this now
i didn't want this i was not looking for
confrontation he opened that door and
i'm thinking okay
here we go because there was no way in
hell i was getting off that elevator at
the command of this whimpering absurd
little person
wasn't going to happen but instead he
stormed off himself his wife exiting
quietly
behind him ashamed i assume and as the
door shut i poked my head out and i said
with true eloquence these were my
actual words and i'm so proud that i
thought to say this in the moment that
just
this eloquent uh quip and come back i
said um
dude seriously and then he said just as
eloquent
yes seriously it's disrespectful
now i'll also mention that another woman
a little older entered the elevator
after that guy got off
and she was wearing a mask too but she
was laughing at the man's antics and
saying that this
this silliness has to end soon that's
what she said she was a normal person
you know a sane person
one of the dwindling few and i almost
hugged her out of sheer gratitude but
then i realized that would be a
violation of elevator etiquette anytime
coveted or not so what i'd really like
to do now is respond briefly to
what the scared man said in the elevator
um or
out of the elevator as the elevator door
shut and respond to to everyone who
finds themselves relating to him
uh or sympathizing with him or anyone
who has acted the same way as him and
there are many of them out there
he said it's disrespectful right and to
that i say
you're absolutely right it is
disrespectful it is
um i am not going to respect
your paranoia i'm not going to respect
your
unreasonable demands i'm not going to
respect your fear
we were going to be standing within a
few feet of each other for 25 seconds
i'm not hacking up a lung i'm not
feverish i'm not sick
now you may not know that about me but i
do
and i'm gonna govern my behavior based
on what i do know
not based on what some stranger doesn't
know
now you might say sure you aren't sick
sure we're only going to be in close
proximity for a few seconds
sure tens of millions of americans are
immune at this point due to vaccination
or prior infection
sure all of those things make it
unlikely that i spread it to someone
else in that context
but but it's not impossible it could
happen yeah it could
true fine but how likely is it
is it likely is it even moderately
likely
is it unlikely but still significantly
plausible
or is it really really very very
unlikely
and if it's the latter which i would
argue it is
then why should i be expected to take
any action to alleviate your
disproportionate fear of a very very
unlikely occurrence
and if i'm expected to take an action
for that reason where does it stop
where does it end what other of your
unreasonable fears am
i it to accommodate
by the way let's take the risk
assessment further
what's a greater risk to you on an
elevator an asymptomatic 34 year old
who'll be standing a few feet from you
for a few seconds or
the elevator itself if anything on that
elevator
kills you is it more likely to be me or
some kind of malfunction of the elevator
at least you must admit that there are
both unlikely occurrences
but neither is impossible and if you're
losing your mind over what is unlikely
but not impossible
why are you on the elevator at all why
not take the stairs
well sure the stairs present their own
risks
as joe biden has shown us every year
many people die from stairs related
accidents
so how else will you get down the lobby
i don't know repel down the
from the window probably not much safer
it is a problem i mean come to think
about how did you get to the hotel in
the first place i assumed you drove
drove what's more on those straight
desert roads where people routinely tip
the speedometer
over 100 miles an hour maybe you flew
before you drove
well that presents all of its own risks
covert related and not covered related
see
every day you do a thousand things that
could kill you
if you were to rank the risk level of
all those things where do i come in
as i breathe in your vicinity for a few
seconds
i'm not at the top i'm quite sure that
not even close to the top
see i know all these things i can make
these reasonable calculations
i even know other relevant data points
like the fact that i very likely already
had coronavirus back in the early days
of the pandemic i'm not sure about that
but it's another factor that's taken
into account which lowers the
statistical risk
now this may not be an equation that
presents itself clearly to you in your
fear but it does to me
and again i am going to act based on
what i
know not based on what you don't
i'm not going to cater to your fear
i shouldn't have to those days have to
be over for all of us
you've had a year of people catering to
your fear
that's done now it's time to live again
get on board with it or stay home hiding
under your bed sobbing and shaking
that's up to you
you can make your own choice and i can
make mine
my choice is to ride the dam elevator
with or without the mask
and also my choice is to cancel
you and that'll do it for us today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
well if you enjoyed this episode don't
forget to subscribe and if you want to
help spread the word please give us a
five star review also tell your friends
to subscribe as well
we're available on apple podcast spotify
wherever you listen to podcasts we're
there also be sure to check out the
other daily wire podcasts including the
ben shapiro show
michael knowles show the andrew clavin
show thanks for listening the matt wall
show is produced by sean hampton
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky
the show is edited by danny d'amico our
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
joe biden can't walk upstairs the white
house admits there's a crisis on the
border and republican governor christie
known
goes weak on transgenderism check it out
on the michael knowles show